bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 3 mai merci
de nous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal comme chaque
jour nous revenons sur votre actualité
locale avec nos invités mais également
avec les journalistes de la rédaction
tout de suite on commence avec les
titres de cette édition
philippe chevrier secrétaire
départemental front national des
yvelines a été et danser ce lundi par
son parti une décision prise suite à la
présence de l'élu au rassemblement du
1er mai organisé par jean marie le pen
ce matin françois fillon l'ancien
premier ministre a lancé son comité de
soutien dans le département l'homme
politique candidat à la primaire de
droite fait partie des douze candidats
déclarés pour cette élection et enfin 8e
édition de la semaine de la mémoire de
l'esclavagé à saint quentin en yvelines
du 4 au 10 mai conférences spectacles
débats organisés sur toute
l'agglomération
le thème de cette année l'héritage
musical d esclavage pour nous en parler
ce soir notre invité maryline luz yeux
porte parole du collectif semaine de la
mémoire de l esclavage et l'élu front
national philippe chevrier a été hier
démis de ses fonctions de secrétaire
départemental le bureau politique du
front national a pris cette décision
suite à la présence de l'élu au
rassemblement organisé le 1er mai par
jean marie le pen philippe chevrier
conserve sa place au parti mais compte
réagir sur cette éviction face à la
presse avant la fin de la semaine
les précisions de william l cette
fonction il occupait depuis huit ans les
du front national philippe chevrier
conseiller municipal à rambouillet et
conseiller régional d'île de france a
été démis hier de son poste de
secrétaire départemental du parti
c'est en raison de sa participation à la
manifestation dédiée à jean marie le pen
a mais il n'est pas possible d'avoir des
des fonctions de sodexo soit
d'encadrement front national en
participant au stylo grand national une
proximité avec jean marie le pen dont
l'élu ne s'est jamais caché depuis son
adhésion au parti jeu
rencontre comme vous l'avez dit
fortement jean marie le pen
évidemment beaucoup de réticences et je
vais poser les questions franches sur
l'antisémitisme la xénophobie sur un tas
de choses et sa réponse a été absolument
de l'éclair s'est montré clair et
convaincant
donc du coup et en même temps bon il
répondait à un souci concernant l'euro
est loué l'ouverture des frontières donc
bah voilà gg j'ai adhéré tout à fait
normalement et puis progressivement j'ai
été responsable de circonscription du
côté de rambouillet depuis mai après
départemental philippe chevrier n'a pour
le moment pas encore donné de réponse
officielle à la presse concernant son
éviction mes comptes communiqués dans
les 48 heures
quand on est impliqué dans un mouvement
politique les partis politiques sur dd
des rouages essentiels de la démocratie
française c'est quelque chose de très
important il faut observer la discipline
de ce parti et les considérations
personnelles d'amitié éventuelle de
fidélité peuvent se passer qu'après
marie christine arnautu vice-présidente
du front national et bruno gollnisch
était aussi présent à la manifestation
du 1er mai et ont été priés de quitter
leurs fonctions
nous restons dans la politique candidat
à la primaire de la droite et du centre
bruno le maire était à versailles hier
soit un déplacement dans le quartier de
satory sur le site et bd comme où se
prépare le véhicule du futur avant de
tenir un nouveau meeting de campagne
ancien ministre de l'agriculture s'est
exprimé devant près de 500 personnes sur
ses propositions et ses dernières
déclarations notamment concernant le
contrôle des coûts dans tiers des
locataires du rsa la soirée aura été
marquée également par une altercation
avec des opposants au mariage pour tous
comme vous voyez à l'image d'une où le
maire a rappelé qu'il ne reviendrait pas
sur la loi est juste après ce journal
dans le cetud politique à suivre
l'entretien réalisé par wilfrid est
riche i avec le député de l'eure il sera
question plus en détails de sa campagne
lui qui figure dans le polo le peloton
de tête selon les derniers sondages
j'en ai les candidats sont aujourd'hui
au nombre de 12 à se présenter à la
primaire de droite selon un récent
sondage près de 23 % des français
seraient prêts à aller voter pour cette
primaire qui aura lieu je le rappelle le
20 et le 27 novembre prochain
françois fillon fait partie des
candidats déclarés dans les yvelines
ses sympathisants se sont rassemblés ce
matin pour lancer le comité de soutien
de l'ancien premier ministre dans le
département un reportage signé mélanie
poté député maire conseillers
départementaux ou régionaux ou encore
chefs d'entreprise ils forment le comité
de soutien de françois fillon
ancien premier ministre et candidat à la
primaire de la droite et du centre qui
sait exactement où en est notre pays
notre pays dans l'europe est notre pays
dans le monde et donc par conséquent il
nous paraît celui qui va pouvoir entamer
des réformes très vite parce que c'est
ce dont le pays a besoin
les réformes c'est pas 4 ans après c'est
pas cinq ans après c'est vraiment dès
que le président est élu
qui plus est maintenant nous sommes dans
un quinquennat en quelques années c'est
vite passé
c'est un homme de conviction et c'est le
seul qui a compris qu il fallait
annoncer les réformes pendant l'élection
pour être légitime et pouvoir les mener
dans les songes oursons jours c'est pas
un vain mot
quand on voit la situation notre pays
aujourd'hui est vraiment allé très vite
dans le dernier sondage le maire de
bordeaux alain juppé est en tête avec
41% d'intentions de vote au premier tour
devant nicolas sarkozy françois fillon
est lui crédité de 9% savez les sondages
au maire
un an de l'élection présidentielle on va
pas rappeler ce qui s'est passé entre
jacques chirac et edouard balladur
mais quand on va véritablement parler
des programmes
je pense que les français auront vite
vers leur choix
nous n'avons pu nous n'avons eu la
possibilité d'être dans les 2000 mesures
pour être candidat à la primaire
françois fillon doit rassembler les
signatures de 250 élus de 2500 adhérents
et de 20 parlementaires le 21 avril
françois fillon grande et public 72
soutien de parlementaires et dans
quelques instants nous passerons à notre
entretien avec anne marie line de luz
yeux sur la semaine de la mémoire de
l'esclavagé en avant cela nous restons
donc continuer à parler politique comme
chaque mardi wilfried errishi nous a
rejoint pour justement parler vos
visites les questions de la primaire en
vue de la présidentielle le bon soir à
will freden soir florent de la primaire
effectivement mais ni de celle qui se
prépare à droite ni de sel hypothétique
à gauche ces derniers mois plusieurs
initiatives plus ou moins citoyenne bien
que parfois aussi un peu politique se
met en place pour désigner un candidat
issu du peuple un candidat désigné de
manière démocratique et transparente
c'est en tout cas ce qui est annoncé
alors il existe plusieurs initiatives de
ce type visant à proposer une
candidature citoyenne pour la
présidentielle 2007
trois initiatives à ce jour la primaire
point org lancé par un entrepreneur et
un avocat la primaire des français point
fr a lancé entre autres par quelques
habitués de la politique cette fois-ci
corinne lepage la présidente de cap 21
ou encore à l'ancien journaliste et
eurodéputé jean marie cavada et puis la
vraie primaire point fr lancé cette
fois-ci entre autres par une élue de
l'opposition
duchesnay sans étiquette c'est donc dans
les yvelines marie durand à ce mets ton
l'écoutent nous expliquer le mode
d'emploi de la vraie primaire point fr
cela se passe sur internet avec les
nouvelles technologies forcément nous
allons profiter de cette technologie qui
est abordable plus facilement qu'est-ce
qui est donc le numérique et nous avons
développé donc une plateforme numérique
la vraie primaire qui a deux modules un
module qui est
le module de la tribune on va dire pour
les candidats donc entre le mois de mars
on lançait le dispositif le 21 mars
jusqu'à fin août
les candidats vont pouvoir s'inscrire et
à partir de septembre nous passons dans
la deuxième phase de la primaire à
savoir le vote
donc ça va se passer en plusieurs étapes
on aura des huitièmes de finale les
quarts de finale demi finale et une
finale pour sortir la plus belle pépite
de cette primaire alors selon l'institut
ifop deux français sur trois souhaite
une primaire organisée en dehors des
partis politiques mais concrètement
est-ce que cela cesse alors si l'on
regarde uniquement à l'exemple de la
vraie primaire qui nous intéresse ce
soir il n'y a aujourd'hui que deux
candidats un conseiller scientifique de
l'ambassade de france et en entrepreneur
c'est assez peu mais l'objectif n'est
pas non plus de multiplier les noms
d'ailleurs pour pouvoir s'inscrire il
faut s'acquitter de 500 euros pour les
organisateurs c'est le moyen de
s'assurer du sérieux des postulants mais
aussi de payer les frais pour la gestion
l'administration du site internet au
quotidien et ne s'agit pas d'engranger
de l'argent pour ensuite par exemple
aider le candidat a mené campagne le
dispositif est uniquement une rampe de
lancement le candidat a désigné devra
ensuite se débrouiller tout seul sur
cette plateforme
il aura besoin de récolter des likes
comme on dit non donc pour être qualifié
pour la phase de vote il devra avoir au
moins 1000 likes et je pense que ça ira
au-delà donc à lui fort de des gens
qu'il aura pu rassembler autour de lui
de sa candidature de constituer son
équipe
alors après je pense qu'on le sait pas
voilà on sera derrière lui on
encouragera mais individuellement pas
par le biais de la vraie primaire alors
ce candidat qui sera désigné par le
processus de la vraie primaire point fr
où les candidats de la primaire point
mort et de la primaire des français
point fr quelle sera sa légitimité
tout va dépendre du nombre de
participants votent bien sûr même s'il y
a tout de même aussi un obstacle de
taille avant ensuite de se présenter
face aux français en 2017 il faudra
recueillir les signatures de 500 élus
d'au moins 30 départements ou
collectivités d'outre-mer différents et
puis à moins des différents que
différents ajustements ne soit décidée
par le conseil constitutionnel
il faudra aussi faire prévaloir cette
légitimité auprès auprès des
institutions en tout cas l'idée montre
qu'il y a une envie citoyenne de
s'approprier le débat politique
cela confirme aussi l envie de renouveau
des français même si l'on peut regretter
que les trois initiatives qui existent à
ce jour n'est pas réussi à fonctionner
ensemble et elle cohabite chacune de
leur côté et c'est le seul regret sur
cette cette idée de primaires défoncé
alors si vous voulez vous lancer vous
aussi dans cette aventure et poté
devenir le prochain président ou la
première présidente de candidates
pourquoi pas j'y réfléchis louis le
président j'ai déjà j'ai déjà beaucoup
de travail coct journal vous savez alors
sur la vraie primaire point fr
l'inscription est possible jusqu'au mois
d'août
wilfrid en tout cas si vous y songez à
votre candidature ce que j'aime aussi
beaucoup et nous passons maintenant à
l'entretien demain mercredi 4 mai et
jusqu'au 10 mai s'ouvre la 8e édition de
la semaine de la mémoire de l'esclavagé
à saint quentin en yvelines
pour nous en parler ce soir en plateau
maryline de lisieux bon vieux par donc
bon soir
vous êtes secrétaire du collectif
semaine de la mémoire de l esclavage
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
pour mieux armés que nous avons invité
de cette semaine alors l'objectif de
cette semaine est de commémorer
également l'évolution de l'escalavage
qui a eu lieu le 10 mai qu'est notre
mémoire retenu nationalement
nationalement ça c'est un événement qui
est suffisamment mis en lumière selon
vous alors notre show en tout cas par
les différentes manifestations que nous
présentons deux
d'attaqué sous des angles divers pas
seulement sur le l'angle historique est
peut-être trop comment dirais-je
scolaire mais les différents aspects
comment dirais-je loisirs
sportif donc toucher tous les publics de
manière à ce que progressivement
il s'intéresse aux autres propositions
comme les conférences qui sont
organisées conjointement et les
expositions donc chasser la 8e édition
chaque année vos organisé justement cet
événement mais est ce que dans toute la
france il ya ces de résonance par
rapport à ça alors dans la mesure ce
n'est pas un jour férié c'est vrai que
ça ne facilite pas la prise par les
associations de la prise en main de
cette date alors il existe
des associations qui qui font état par
exemple dans un collectif s'est faite
qui s'appelle collectif paca dans le sud
de la france qui s'est bien emparés et
qui fonctionne tout au long de l'année
qui met en lumière un certain nombre de
manifestations et nous c'est vrai que
nous partons un peu sous ce modèle-là
même si à l'origine on ne le connaissais
pas mais nous sommes partis un peu sous
ce même modèle à se dire que plutôt que
de commémorer sur une journée peut-être
en proposant sur l'ensemble d'une
semaine des manifestations diverses
tout public de tous âges ça permettra
effectivement que
une commande et une appropriation
progressive par leur part l'ensemble de
la population
le but c'est forcément de sensibiliser
voilà les habitants de saint quentin en
yvelines à ce pan de l'histoire foncé
qui est très important le thème de cette
année est centré sur l'héritage musical
esclavage le rythme de chants les danses
pourquoi avoir choisi ce thème alors
chaque année nous choisissons un fil
rouge parce qu'il est bien bien entendu
le thème de l'esclavagé ce n'est je vais
pas dire ça peut ça peut créer quelques
réticences de part et d'autre un que ce
soit les les antilles et ou descendants
de 10 descendants d'esclaves
parce que dans dans leur génération ou
dans leur histoire en histoire de leur
île lesca basse et s'est inscrite comme
un événement majeur que ce soit aussi
côté métropolitain où effectivement
comment dirais-je il n'y a pas forcément
envie de s'attarder sur cet événement
notre propos n'est pas de chercher né
des responsables et de générer des
culpabilités mais plutôt de se dire que
voilà c'est un moment de l'histoire
il est ce qu'il est et il faut en il
faut faire progresser de part et d'autre
les regards donc l'objectif c'est un
petit peu de parler de l' esclavage mais
de la bordée d'une autre façon de tous
ou tout sous tous ses aspects parce que
c'est vrai qu'on ignore
parce que c'est peut-être pas
suffisamment mis en valeur que certains
c'est une rythmique elles sont
spécifiques et elles ont traversé l oms
l ont été appropriées par parler
les africains qui ont été déportés et
ils se sont appropriés à la fois le
métissage déjà africains qui existaient
puisque les déportés n'était pas
nécessairement de la même et elle
n'était absolument pas de la même de la
même tribu et n'avaient pas les mêmes
rituels
ni la musique ni la même langue et c est
arrivé sous des îles différentes aussi
ils se sont appropriés a aussi la
musique des des colons et c'est ce mixte
çà et là qui donne les musiques
afro-cubaines les musiques afro
antillaise la musique dite noire aux
etats-unis et tout ça à la réunion le
maloya et c'est donc tout ça c'est vrai
que c'est important de rappeler que
c'était un mode de résistance parce que
la résistance n'est pas forcément armé
c'est vraiment modern art c'est là c'est
un mode de résistance et ce mode de
résistance là il a permis à ces
personnes de créer de la résilience
parce que c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez c'est terrible d'être d'être mis
en esclavage et donc la musique a permis
de la résilience et c'est une forme de
résistance parce que ça a permis de
créer un une nouvelle musique et quand
on voit aux états unis maintenant la
musique noire c'est quasiment elle qui
domine le marché
alors justement c'est un héritage très
important jeudi soir en france tels new
partout dans le monde que l'on retrouve
dans notre société contemporaine vous
mettez aussi l'accent justement sur cet
héritage dans à la semaine de la mémoire
esclavage voilà donc tout cet héritage
là donc si vous regardez le le programme
notamment du samedi 7
c'est vrai que donc il ya une exposition
chaque année il ya en fonction de la de
fil rouge il ya une exposition qui qui
va balayer le thème et des conférences
qui vont aussi bas les thèmes donc la
journée qui va véritablement être sur
cette thématique de la musique des
répètes steira c'est la journée du 7 qui
est à au conseil de l'agglomération avec
comme vous le voyez
l'exposition phare qu'est ce que le
vernissage aura lieu à 15 heures des
conférences avec un griot donc et un
griot moderne parce que si
expliquer aux gens qui me connaissent
pas ce que c'est alors le griot en
afrique c'est quelqu'un qui puisqu'on
est dans l'oralité
c'était lui qui permettait de 30 de
transmettre l'histoire comme un compteur
alors c'est pas véritablement compteur
c'est un compteur de l'histoire des
familles des tribus et quelque part
c'était le livre d'histoire est donc
maintenant c'est vrai qu'on on on n'a
gardé que l'aspect musical parce que
c'est vrai qu'il racontait tout ça en
chantant parce que ça ça permet
peut-être de mieux mémoriser aussi qui
n'a pas appris ça une leçon en chantant
comme dit la chanson
et donc c'est probablement ça a
contribué aussi à transmettre à cette
transmission est que comment dire allez
les tribunes n'oublient pas leur leur
histoire est que traverse même d'autres
d'autres pays puisque les griots ils
étaient vraiment des itinérants du
spectacle alors les donc les points
forts donc de cette semaine donc c'est
demain l'ouverture jeudi à 5 mais
également il ya aussi ce qui se passe
samedi et le point d'or que c'est le 10
mai voilà un grand savant toujours à
coeur de terminer alors c'est vrai que
les discussions qui nous ont conduits à
choisir ses dates là c'était sa voix est
ce qu'on commençait par le dit mais où
est ce qu ont terminé par le 10 mai
finalement on a opté pour terminer un
point d'orgue avec le dis mais pas ce
que c'est la date qui a été retenue
nationalement et ça nous permet à ce
moment-là de porter l'accent sur cette
date là avec des
selon quand c'est un week-end c'est plus
facile parce qu'on peut porter beaucoup
plus d'action mais là vous voyez on
termine avec un très beau spectacle qui
est proposée par illicites dans ses
mails invoice ils ont créé cette comédie
musicale là qui s'appelle qui sache elle
ôte tes chaînes et qu' il faut savoir
lors c'est déjà guichet fermé donc
dommage mais sachez que je crois que
vers septembre
ils proposeront ce spectacle là et donc
parfois on le souhaite on leur souhaite
bonne chance avec ce spectacle se laver
une nouvelle est ailleurs alors
l'événement d'ouverture donc qui a lieu
demain à 9 heures se fera avec des
enfants des classes de primaire
notamment c'est important de les
associer justement à cette thématique
même s'ils sont assez jeunes quand même
alors c'est vrai que quand on regarde
les livres d'histoire il ya des moments
il ya des points d'entrée pour pouvoir
parler cela mais ça reste des choses
vraiment très très succincte ou vraiment
comment dire assez réductrice
donc ça nous paraissait important aussi
dans notre comment dirais-je notre
mission entre guillemets que nous sommes
auto octroyés mais tout de même
c'était peut-être d'apporter nos de
contribuer par nos efforts par les
expositions que nous que nous créons ce
que ça veut dire que nous avons au moins
8 les huit expositions qui sont
disponibles et qui peuvent être
commandés est proposé aux écoles
qu'elles peuvent solliciter et ses
expositions peuvent être mis à
disposition des écoles
c'est important parce que c'est
l'histoire c'est notre histoire commune
et comment dirais-je pour que tout le
monde puisse vivre en paix et en
harmonie
c'est important de savoir
sans recherche de revanche c'est
vraiment indispensable de comprendre que
chacun a apporté sa pierre à l'édifice
qui est maintenant la nation française
c'est un moyen d'approfondir peut-être
d'améliorer également le vivre ensemble
il ya des conférences des débats sur des
thèmes qui sont qui sont organisés voilà
au tour justement de clerval c'est un
moyen de combattre aussi certains
clichés qui ont toujours peut-être la
vie dure je pense notamment à aller aux
clichés qui sont abordés et débats et
tables rondes c'était un choix de votre
part
oui alors notamment celui les lois anti
le rythme dans sexe et la voilà
effectivement bon alors c'est à la fois
le le clin d'oeil et puis effectivement
parce que même nous on pourrait être
dans ceux acceptés et intégré au ces ce
cliché la bombe à la question du rythme
c'est la question de l'éducation de
l'environnement dans lequel on vit et il
ya des noix qui ont pas leur aide mais
il ya des noix qui on entendrait mais il
ya des blancs qui ont le rythme et a
débloqué non pas le rythme et ça c'est
important aussi de casser certains codes
certains clichés qui font que on
stigmatise
à tort en réservant dépend de ce qu'on
veut c'est que un enfant d'origine noire
forcément métissé de façon à l'heure
actuelle en tout cas pour ce qui relève
de nos pays de dom-tom doivent se dire
ben je peux tout mais ouvert je peux je
ne peux pas être que footballeur ou que
musicien ou que je peux être ingénieur
je peux être de tous les toits aux
politiques etc prendre ma place et
m'investir politiquement ou dans
d'autres domaines de recherche
développés et bien ce sera le mot de la
fin merci beaucoup marine l'usd est
revenu sur notre plateau lors je le
rappelle la semaine de mai la mémoire à
50 ans d'une souris ce lavage ça
commence demain c'est jusqu'au 10 mai si
vous voulez plus d'informations
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran merci à vous fin et un mot de golf
à présent le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines a réouvert ce samedi
le parcours de l'albatros
après dix mois de fermeture pour travaux
pour l'occasion un évier un événement
baptisé on se bouge a été organisée au
programme un concours de précision et
des animations avec l'ancien joueur de
l'european tour david edwards au niveau
du tronc numéro 11
regardez ce reportage si mickael miro et
patrick jacques de dixmude
après dix mois d'abstinence les golfeurs
de 50 ans ni vie non plus à nouveau
taper la balle blanche ce samedi sur les
greens de l'albatros le parcours était
fermé pour travaux en vue de la ryder
cup 2018
pour fêter cette réouverture les
responsables du centre ont organisé une
journée baptisée 11 bouge avec des
animations c'est de dire aux gens ben
voilà on ré ouvre on est ouverts revenez
découvrir parce qu'il faut redémarrer la
machine pour nous
on n'a pas pu accueillir ses clients
pendant dix mois maintenant il faut
qu'on fasse une opération de séduction
pour qu'il revienne pour que l'opération
séduction fonctionne la journée a débuté
par un show humoristique avec l'ancien
golfeur de l'european tour david edwards
le sportif a présenté à cette occasion
ses techniques
j'espère que les gens ont aimé mon show
et que tout le monde va chercher à
revenir encore au golf national de saint
quentin en il ya vraiment quelque chose
de très très spécialisés
après le show les 1000 golfeurs présents
pendant la journée en plus s'essayer à
un concours de précision trou numéro 11
le secteur était totalement remodelée
avec un lac et les difficultés ont été
modifiés donc je trouve que le trou il a
beaucoup changé est très grand très
grand
un plan d'eau beaucoup plus gros que la
normale est assez impressionnant
les professionnels découvriront le
nouveau parcours de l'albatros à
l'occasion de l'open de france
la compétition est programmée du 30 juin
au 3 juillet à saint quentin en yvelines
les petits chanteurs de demain s'étaient
donné rendez vous samedi à cerner la vie
c'est ici que s'est déroulé ce week-end
le deuxième la deuxième édition du
concours de chant organisé par le
cabaret du bout des traits une chance
pour les enfants de montrer leur talent
regardez ce reportage signé james square
c'est un jour que ces jeunes talents ne
sont pas prêts d'oublier
dix huit enfants ont participé à la
deuxième édition du concours de chant du
cabaret du goût des prêts à cerner la
ville samedi dernier ils ont chanté
devant un jury composé de professionnels
de la télévision
on va essayer d'apprécier au mieux la
performance de chacun des enfants
les enfants sont divisés en trois
catégories d'âge parce que forcément on
peut pas comparer une performance fait
par un enfant de six ans avec celle d'un
enfant de 14 ou 15 ans déjà pour
certains auraient bu et il ya des gens
qui peuvent chanter moyennement bien là
mais dont on sent qu'ils ont qui peuvent
avoir quelque chose ou dans la
personnalité ou dans effectivement le
futur timbre de voix
une bonne occasion de découvrir le monde
du spectacle le concours proposé des
prix adaptés aux gagnants de chaque
catégorie
le premier prix est un enregistrement
studio pour pouvoir éventuellement
enregistré la chanson qui sera faite par
le gagnant le deuxième prix et la
possibilité d'aller dans une dans une
émission de télé vu qu'on a des parents
est maintenant une marraine qui
éventuellement pourraient nous de la
cité d'ouvrir l'envers du décor donc
voilà et puis le troisième prix c'est la
possibilité aux petits d'aller voir un
spectacle sur paris qui est un qui est
un one man show pour enfants
si les jeunes participants avaient la
pression de la scène certains n'oublient
pas que le concours peut leur servir de
tremplin
the van jets c'est le rêve de tout le
monde alors ça c'est chouette
entraînements les enfants ont offert aux
spectateurs un véritable show et
certains sont déjà prêts à revenir
l'année prochaine
ces débats ont bien utilisé c'est la fin
de cette édition merci de nous avoir
suivis rester avec nous dans un instant
vous retrouvez wilfried richy pour le
7-8 politique quant à moi je vous
retrouve demain pour le journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée